well whether he can do it or not
obviously the governor of New York
Andrew Cuomo would like to be the
president meanwhile his brother over at
CNN wants you to think that he has risen
from the dead as well several weeks ago
he contracted coronavirus we expressed
sympathy for him that night it was
totally sincere we haven't criticized
him in any way since then but then we
watched him seize every chance to remind
everyone watching that he was very sick
and in very strict containment I'm doing
the show as you know in my basement and
Co vid containment is this the new
normal
this is how it's gonna be no I can't
always be in my basement you can't
always be in your house we got to get
back to work I'm down in the basement
we're doing it super strict
I hear it's not easy it is necessary I
know it's what a lot of us want to hear
hell I want to hear it governor I'm sick
of being in my basement I want to get
out well thankfully Cuomo got better
more happy to hear that not kidding
but CNN shameless Cheez balls that they
are celebrated by filming Cuomo rising
like a buff cable news Lazarus from the
grave and back into ordinary life we are
a huge day today in Kazakh whoa mo take
a look at this all right here is the
official ranch from the basement cleared
by CDC little sway just worked out
happens this is what I've been dreaming
of literally for weeks this is the dream
just to be back up here doing normal
things
when did your no let's start talking
about themselves so much it's not a
story it's narcissism and that's weird
enough but it's not all that was faked
just last week
Cuomo admitted getting into a fight with
a bicyclist who harassed him for going
outside and congregating with other
people something CNN has been vilifying
ordinary people for wanting to do I
don't want some Jack loser fat tire
biker to be able to pull over and get
him my face and in my space
and talk to me I don't want to hear it
by the way if you're the Jackass loser
fat tired bicyclists you're always
welcome on this show we'd love to hear
from you that whole exchange seems kind
of unpleasant but there's a scandal
underneath it here you have a top CNN
anchor who appears to have been ignoring
the social distancing rules his network
has been promoting and forcing on
everyone else it seems like he wasn't
telling the truth about staying
quarantined in his basement which can't
be to me in his own video was
humiliating enough